17 to 20 live bodies when they join
these drills so guys get rest Plumbly
couldn't get the milsat pants here comes
LeBron to be able to do this rebound
Coast the coast I mean he's driving past
guards getting all the way to the rim
light 23 to pull up he shows you the
basketball and it makes it easier for
you to get stripped here come the Lakers
on the ride left-handed a handful in the
last three years he looked kuzmin's way
but he says I see you Brandon and
Brandon the recipie I think you I know
you can get away with it great pass by
LeBron that's a play that Cleveland ran
successful action at the elbow and look
at Stevenson with a great defensive play
three on two for the Lakers James
instead of the bling it's
and flexes how about LeBron James
clearly the graph on movie but the role
man's strength the ability to spin and
finish the opposite hand what a move
good McKeen with the board two seconds
to go
James a buzzer beater
[Applause]
[Music]
Susy
and nails a LeBron James closes out the
first half with a 40-footer
[Music]
[Applause]
nice pass to heart for down by three
they can tie the game with seven his sex
in years LeBron LeBron for the time of
the evening LeBron with the croc winding
down long three-pointers calmly knock
signs as a Miss Laker team they've been
losing quotes game does LeBron goes
one-on-one three passes tonight they're
really been special he's kind of time by
Lonzo and the pawn says I thought if
you're moving I see you I'll get it you
[Applause]
lead is six
we need another one team one the Wooden
Award this guy I like this mindset turns
down the jump up puts his head down
attacks but Lillard can't pay it off
team player
in the discussion for the best to do it
and this is an incredible path the warm
side of your labor it looks different
from the other
[Applause]
he's got 27 and taking over Staples
Center big time blocked by LeBron on a
defensive end I say enough about to
change the direction off the dribble
scam shows you that first one Isaacson
always says where did he go we went to
the rim and he finished that the rim did
the next trip down will spin contact use
the left flex yep
we know you're strong it come in there
it goes / LeBron nearly 40% on the year
from downtown he's got 13 in the first
half magic made 8 of their lap
Northwestern Wildcats
down say goodnight
Lakers are on their way to a win over
the Mavericks he's just saying I'm gonna
set us come sit nah just stay there let
me shoot this one from about thirty
substitution thirteen six runs since
LeBron dented back into this ball game
takes it the clock for James a deep
three
[Applause]
by the stanchion he'll get a free throw
running downhill number 23 you are clear
for takeoff the whistle just throw it up
he just threw it up hit with righty and
he's got a three-point opportunity here
after not getting many calls in the
first end he says okay I'll just split a
couple of defenders and then go up and
get to finish his Turner with the foul
and LeBron with the three-point
opportunity from downtown picked off
he's a great play recognition
by the young fella throwing the ball
look the beautiful open when the Lakers
are at their best in the lack of Ceuta
can steal he's among the leaders in
steals by Portland for instance
[Applause]
somewhere tape backing LeBron that's
what were they used to do out to Ian
Clark for three no good
long rebound Kuzma James goes to the
missed it batted out to Rondo a little
bit of resistance there at the read by
the lake a ten-to-one run by the Lakers
first fourth quarter turnover by New
Orleans like a Randle being physical
with James shot clock down to four
LeBron lost it now he gains fires away
[Applause]
I've seen that a lot as an opposing
coach that's my boy the next year look
at this shot I mean you can't play the
defense any better than that
that's a great possession that's a great
defensive possession and it just breaks
your heart on those you know it bears
that length to get in that time being
used on the glass you see the reach that
is incredible
certainly can
Hickerson must win mode a good hard
drive there's the Pablo why just dunk it
when you can reverse dunk it the king is
in the house and it's worthy of multiple
looks he fits perfectly with this group
[Applause]
ask to play Luke was super animated but
he goes past Elias sobah and Mirotic
says that probably don't want to mess
with that
Milwaukee hears Rondo gets it to James
LeBron takes it to the rim and finishes
with the left and he's fouled jinda
LeBron continues
[Applause]
his idol NJ bird fourth on the all-time
scoring list we see the delivery from
Rondo LeBron making history just clicked
over 20 he put on a show with that way
mr. Carlos camp has the turnover and
Cousteau's it out of head and wrong off
the bounce
[Applause]
Oh Oh Showtime he gets in the open court
and does this to block the shot
[Applause]
by LeBron to turn over the Angela says
I've got me an easy one whoops where did
he come from
that's called recovery cyclone gets the
spin to go in just never surprised at
everything he can do amazing boy and
don't feel bad Sam and I've been in the
same situation they want my boy to do
something special like a trip except if
the croc says yeah I better go to work
here goes to the basket seller gets to
contact LeBron which then puts it in his
left hand
yeah we know you you saw
[Applause]
giving up the middle but he recovers and
just keeps his eye on it
jhaza lay it up soften you got to attack
with aggression in this league though
she's gonna see a lot of shots going the
other direction if you can flush it
yeshuaa the fresh air LeBron this year
and Jordan pools seconds to make a jump
to kind of deflected like that would go
that was just read a beautiful block but
he should be on the line especially
couldn't plays like this where the LOB
throws it up over two minutes into the
second quarter tack Corky and Jen
flushed him Wow almost vintage look how
high he was on that blood
and follow ads with defense by
karl-anthony towns and company that's a
throw Houston Joe Wright to LeBron right
to LeBron in his LA I'm taking this you
see the shot clock up there were 22 on
it when he went through the net we saw
placeable team and keep away says I see
what you're going to do is go to the rim
I'll just throw it up and you do the
rest and cook do the wrist he does turns
it down
[Applause]
[Applause]
the job of getting back and preventing
an easy deuce to then civilly at the
time everything starts with defense the
Lakers are patrolling the pain and
getting out in the early offense and the
pencil Abravanel did Anthony day was
showing them what they came to see here
I mean that pass couldn't have been any
better bounds by kcpt LeBron look how
perfectly that better
hi LeBron was come on that was nice
Lakers have 10 points in the paint
already in this game to see the
difference but once you see the spin of
LeBron James it's no mess around after
that it's direct line drive to the cup
that's his favorite spot
now it's James to our one
offensive foul here's that throw down by
LeBron as he throws it down that looks
did you like it tandem is there's been
with the reversal in Fame whereas as
James get the beautiful pass won't visit
here in the regular season
dangerous pass Caruso deflects it James
right back to Caruso back to James and
it's an eight-point game great
anticipation and then vision and again
you're not finding this type of tenacity
athleticism and vision at the park well
Frank Vogel see
[Applause]
to Houston please show us that again
that's a little bit of Dominique off one
leg he's the double pump it bring it
down there's some new stop was a big one
before the all-star break that ot win in
Denver Moran do we admit it now the
Lakers have numbers that's a great
decision by the bronze ition is avery
gives it to LeBron who gives it right
away to Danny Green who Wow just throw
it up letting a Braun do the rest and do
the rest he does just flushes it in the
crowd oh boy they love see the Lakers
[Applause]
okay well see it's a little bit easier
at the rim until you meet your Vail
rejected by the game teams goes behind
the back and then reverse layup is good
[Applause]
eleven and a quarter Wow James
about 28 feet
I think the Zion dunk may be trigger
that shot by James from within a
spotlight in making the most of it which
then led to this that was past 30 and
it's Davis who pulls down the rebound
out duals LeBron for that board the last
couple of games seven turnovers James
nearly walked Howard throws it back up
top to Davis Danny Green to James James
gets in the pane and finishes Middleton
just four for 15 from the field
James finding his spot goes inside wipes
out see how deep Lopez's and look at
Magee he's not rolling to try to get a
pass from James because he knows Lopez
is so deep there's no roll going to be
available he rolls to try to take out
the shot blocker
[Applause]